you have been
in the military most of your life as
have i um
what what advice would you have for um
for those that are transitioning out of
the military into the civilian world
what are the things
particularly if you're going to lead an
organization what are the things that
you ought to think about maybe three
things that
that come to mind that since you've been
out for a while now
um well you know i i think first and
foremost i think it's
it's important to develop your own
uh habits on making sure you're informed
on the issues whether they are issues in
the national security arena or whether
they're issues in the business world
and i i think it's really important to
get a habit
in place whether you know the websites
the journals the other sources of
information that you go to
that give you a broad understanding of
what's going on so i think it's
important to be
to be informed uh and then i think it's
important to kind of read
write and discuss uh what's what's
happening on here i think this is uh
this is an important part of our of our
process i think and don't
shouldn't be afraid of doing those types
things and talking to people about
uh what's going on there and then i i
would say you know
kind of figure out what your role is in
in this uh
whether you're going to be in you know
you're trying to advise people about
things
or you're actually going to be
participating in the decision making and
stuff like that so
um i think yeah you know it's kind of
those things right there be informed
don't be afraid to talk to people write
write your write your ideas down and do
a lot of reading
secretary mattis news again very
influential in my life
uh you know often reminded all of us of
that that the importance of just having
a grounding in
in in good history of why things are i
mean
this is fun this is fundamental in a
place like centcom frankly
um because the underlying attentions are
so deep and it's not
any different i think in the civilian
world and i think trying to understand
that is important and then
you know finding finding what your role
is going to be and then trying to fill
into the best way you can
you